hello everyone and welcome back to the
air things masters we are uh in the
semi-finals in a match between daniel
lubovo and timur
and the two of their first games ended
in a draw then tamer won
game three and this is now game four
dubo needs a win here
uh so he can draw the first match and
then go into match two looking for a win
or if he draws the game uh or loses then
uh
rajab wins the match so without further
ado uh let's check it out and uh before
uh we
before we check out the game i would
just like to mention uh i do have some
very nice merchandise for you
i haven't updated my merch shop for like
two years but
uh i haven't had any designs so here is
a very nice design by adam genesis
uh it's uh paul morphy rocking the
captures power glove so if you guys are
interested in this you can check it out
i will put a link in the description
below uh also some nice uh
mugs and some ornaments are are featured
there if you guys are interested in that
uh so that being said let's check out
the game uh
dooba with the white pieces opens with
e4
uh we have c5 by rajab of knight to f3
knight
to c6 and d4 now so striking at the
center just a normal open sicilian see
captures on d for knight captures and
now e5
uh keying this knight away and you don't
really gain anything by capturing you
will simply improve black's position in
the center so knight to b5 now with idea
so maybe knight to d6
check and black defense knights to the
uh sorry d6 and not
knight to c3 and now if you're not ready
and this knight comes to d5 then you
might have problems as both of the
knights will be attacking that c7 square
so here
a6 kicking the knight back knight back
to a3 and
now b5 uh interestingly rajab already
had this position uh
in the previous month in the skilling
open against wesley so where bishop the
e6 was played
and their game ended in a draw so of
course udubo is uh
familiar familiar with this and he
probably prepared something very nice
for rajabov
so b5 uh we have knight to d5 and now
comes
knight to f6 attacking the knight here
and dubo just pins it bishop to g5
uh sometimes when i have this position
for example if i'm playing bullet or
something i will go bishop to e3 it's a
very sneaky move
it's not a good move but unless your
opponent knows the absolute best rook to
b8 you will you will have a very nice
game and sometimes your opponent will
just play something weird like bishop to
e7
and then you win the game with just
bishop to b6
so yeah i've done it plenty of times so
you can try it tonight to c7 check and
that's it
uh a bit of a cheapo but you know if it
works
so bishop to g5 of course uh doesn't try
something like that against rajabov
and bishop to e7 now and here just
bishop captures on f6 and now this
knight on d5
reigns supreme so bishop captures on f6
and now
c3 c4 is also possible uh duba prefers
c3 and
now uh bishop back to g5 not allowing
this knight to
have this constant pressure on the
bishop uh interestingly uh wesley so had
uh the this exact position against rajab
of also in the scaling open they played
two games in this line
uh their rook the b8 was played by uh by
rajab but here we have bishop to g5 so
the job of deviates from the game he
played against wesley so
and now knights to c2 dubo prepares to
bring
the other knight back into the game
we've broke the b8 now and only now
h4 uh in this position the absolute
top move uh that's always played is a4
but dubo switches it up and goes for h4
instead it's not a new move it has been
played before
bishop back to h6 by the chavo i'm not
interested in picking up the pawn you
can capture the pawn but
if you don't know why you're capturing
the pawn and do this is all well within
dubose preparation
you you don't capture the pawn so bishop
back to h6
and now again there are some uh games
where a4 was played where g3 was played
where g4 was played but uh we have
bishop to e2 by do both
and it is only as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see what happens here uh
castles by the top of and
now bishop to g4 by do both uh placing
this bishop on this long diagonal and
preparing uh some very
nice trick g4 is also looking very scary
if g5 comes uh black could be could be
in trouble but
if g4 bishop to f4 and then who who who
can tell what's really happening here
so instead bishop to g4 by do both end
bishop to e6 now better job of making
room for the queen so he can get a
double attack on the bishop
and here again king to f1 like we said
in the previous video king f1 is the new
castles now players just want to play
king f1 and bring the rook
into the game to attack the opponent's
king
so here queen to d7 with a double attack
on the bishop here
and now you could uh try a lot of ideas
here but the duo finds the
the most interesting one bishop to f5
and now what's the plan with bishop to
f5 it seems like you're giving up
a pawn but not really because if bishop
captures here e
captures and queen captures do you see
how white wins here
it's a very interesting line so even
feel free to pause the video and
win this game for white while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on winning the
queen
or rather the knight and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight c
to b4 and now the knight is lost uh the
knight is lost because
whatever you do if the knight captures
just 97 check
picks up the queen if you defend the
knight it's all the same doesn't really
matter
you could even try and defend it with
the queen but it still doesn't matter
you still just pick up the knight it's a
free knight if queen captures then this
picks up the queen so in no way can you
defend the
the defend this knight so a very tricky
idea by
baidubo but rajabo of course figures it
out he plays king to h8 now the king is
well uh
beyond the reach of this knight and now
queen to h5
dubaf's pieces are coming closer and
closer to the java's king and
only now bishop captures on f5 and here
e captures on f5 by dubois saying that
this will be an extremely strong pawn
maybe g4 g5 in the future will be
possible
queen captures on f5 was also an option
for example queen captures and
now if black goes in for the trade now
you play e captures with the threat of
f6
and if black pushes f6 then you go g4
and it could be a very
very tricky line rogue g1 maybe you're
threatening g5 but again
it's hard to say uh what's happening
here and also dubo is already down in
the match by a point so he really
needs a win he can't uh drag it out to
to some sort of a draw so e captures an
f5 instead keeping the tension
and now of course you do not want to
allow white to push f6 so black pushes
f6
and now rook to d1 by dubof bringing
that rook into the game
and rajabov goes a5 he just continues
advancing his pawn on the queen side he
says i'm very safe here on the king's
side
and duboff again rook to h3 going for
that attack
uh similar to what we've seen uh in the
game uh
lebanon played against maxine varsha
lagrave uh bringing that uh
rook into the game or uh rather no not
maxine
uh who was it against eleven played
against someone
can't remember i i'm going to blame it
on the anesthesia so rook to h3 and now
rook beat the e8 here you you you're
basically deciding between
rook b to e8 followed by e4 or maybe
trying to get this
knight away from d5 with something like
knight to e7
and now for example captures captures in
rook h2 d3 going after this pawn
which is of course playable uh but uh
arjabo doesn't like that so he
instead goes rook to the rook to e8 we
have rook
h to d3 now again with uh two rooks and
d file now after the knight moves this
pawn will be under attack
and here we have a very interesting e4
move and now
uh dubo needs to decide what to do here
does he move the rook or does he play
something else uh and uh
more often than not the dubo will play
something else so here
knight captures on f6 and what do you
play here
the queen and rook are under attack uh
if you capture with
uh with the pawn then the bishop will be
hanging
also the rook can capture on d6 so
capturing with the pawn really makes no
sense so here rook captures an
f6 and now the d6 pawn is defended twice
so what was dubo's idea here
well duo's idea was rook captures and d6
and now again we have this crazy
position where
uh yes the d6 square was guarded twice
but there's also the problem of the rook
being an e8 so
rajabo has to be very careful here so
you either capture the rook on d6 with
rook captures on d6
rook captures and v6 and now bring the
queen to c8
keeping an eye on both of these uh
pieces which seems to be quite passive
for black so instead rajabo goes for
rook captures on f5 he wants to trade
queens here
and now the thing is uh dubo has six
minutes on the clock where his rajapur
has only three minutes on the clock
and here rook captures on c6 by dubose
so again
if queen captures then the queen no
longer guards the rook you pick up the
rook
so here rajabov plays the absolute best
rook captures an f2 with
check he has to give up this rook so he
best grabs some material while he's at
it
king captures and only now queen
captures on c6 and we get this crazy
position where the material is
completely equal
and who knows what's happening uh uh her
job of skiing is much safer he
or she has a very strong pass pawn here
but
again uh his pieces are also somehow
somewhat
tied down to the defense of each other
so here uh you don't want to allow rook
to f8 to come with check first do both
brings the king to safety
king to g1 and here rajab goes for
b4 and again interestingly it's four
minutes for dublin and only 50 seconds
for a job of
but he does get a 10 seconds increment
per move so it's not
all that terrible and here uh you decide
between queen captures on a5 or just
c captures on b4 uh dubo decided for c
captures and b4 both are fine
uh and now comes a captures on b4 of
course you don't capture the knight
because queen capture 78 will be
checkmate
so we have a captures on b4 and now
again
knight captures on b4 and now dubo
grabbed the pawn and he has two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
if he can get to them rolling up the
board will be very good for him but of
course
rajabo will try everything that so that
that it doesn't happen
queen to b6 with check connecting with
the knight
but again you will not be able to
capture the knight because the java's
rook
is still hanging here so king to h1 of
course you cannot go to f1 because of
rook f8 to check and only now
rook to f8 this like we already
mentioned loses the queen captures
so rook to f8 now this threat is finally
a reality and now uh dubo just plays a3
now there's no uh plan to it he didn't
want to
move the knight uh uh anywhere all that
quickly maybe you could have done knight
to d5 sacrifice the b two pawn but
rajabov is extremely low on time
and dubo is trying to make use of that
and here e3
he uh here ojabo just starts pushing his
past pawn with queen to e5 by dubo
now with some very sneaky ideas of let's
say rook to d6 attacks the queen and
then
rook captures bishop because the pawn
cannot capture it's pinned
uh and here uh rajab almost lost on time
with one second on the clock
rajava played uh queen to uh g6 now the
queen is very safe here
uh and uh dubois continued now with
knight steady five he started bringing
his uh
knight into the game with queen to c2
immediately duo spent quite a lot of
time for this move so the job of
played queen to c2 instantly attacking
the rook and the pawn uh
always uh a very important principle and
just use your opponent's time
uh and now rook to g1 and this is where
things start to go wrong for dubai
because uh he needs to keep an eye on
that h4 pawn rook to d4
that is the superior move here but it's
very unnatural when you're low on time
to
move the rook away from the back rank as
this pawn is coming
very very close to e1 so rook to g1 by
double and now
queen to f2 immediately going after that
h4 pawn that's why we said that maybe
rook on d4 would have been better
and queen to e7 now if the queen moves
of course you will be able to capture
the rook but uh
rajabo has no uh plans of uh moving that
uh
queen so e2 and now comes knight to c3
with
a double attack on the pawn here from
the queen and the knight
but here comes a brilliancy by rajab of
bishop g5 and there there were a lot of
other good moves for rajab
but bishop to g5 is just the the
absolute best one because he wants to
get
the queen away from the e file and the
point is you don't even have to capture
the bishop but it doesn't help
for example after the queen moves now
you can block with the bishop so
uh there are other ways you can play
this position and now of course uh the
the white queen no longer guards the one
square but double also very long time he
grabs the bishop
and now comes e1 queen and now black has
two queens on the board
for the moment rook captures on e1 of
course this is forced
queen captures with check came to h2 and
now we have this position
where it's uh queen and rook for a java
against queen and knight for duplo but
duval still has his two pass pawns here
if he can start pushing them
uh it's all good but that's easier said
than done here at a job of goes h6 he
has to make some breeding room for his
king so he can start activating the rook
and the queen to g3 now offering a queen
trade but rajab will be no rush to do so
queen to c1 now he wants to play rook to
f1 bring the rook over to h1
hopefully uh end the game very quickly
so
queen to d6 attacking the rook and now
rook to f1
uh the knight is far too uh far away
for uh you know uh to be used in some
checkmating sequences he needs at least
one move
to d5 so he can start going somewhere
like maybe e7 g6 and so on
uh but that's a lot of moves so queen d8
to check we have king to h7 and queen to
d3
with check king h8 and now duval could
repeat this rajava would also be very
happy to
repeat because if the game ends in a
drop then rajaba wins the first match
so dubu needs to find something else he
goes knight the e4
and now rook to h1 with check he had to
allow this and now the king hunt begins
king g3 we have queen captures on b2 uh
rajab even takes some time to grab a
pawn here
we have queen to d8 with czech king to
h7 and now
queen back to d3 threatening some very
nasty discoveries
here uh if the king remains there so of
course you need to move it but first
king the e5 this comes with check king
to g4
and now queen to e6 with check again
rajabo very happy with the draw
king f4 and now rook captures an h4
check
king to e3 and now rook to g4 going
after even more pawns also rook to g3
check would be deadly
because the knight cannot move so king
to f3 attacking the rook here
and now queen to f5 with check king e3
and now comes queen to f4 with check
king to d4
and queen to d6 check and it was in this
position that daniel dubo resigned the
game
as the position is completely lost uh
and
uh well he he really needs a win to get
to
the time match one which is not
happening in this position because if
you go back
then just queen to f4 check and would be
very happy repeating this position
or if king d4 king the queen d6 back and
now you try running away here then it's
just queen e5 and you are losing this
piece and then of course uh
black will win even faster so duba of
course knew this after queen to d6 check
he resigned the game and
what uh what an incredible victory by
timur a job of not only in the game
but also in the match uh as he won this
match by a two-point margin first two
games were drawn and then rajab
won two games in a row so very
impressive uh the
display of skill better job of and
something i found very weird that people
are
uh you know weirded out but by how rajab
is playing this strong but rajavov has
always been incredibly strong so
i don't know what's uh uh what's all
what's all the fuss about i mean he got
into the candidates tournament and then
just you know said i'm not going to play
and he's been crushing everyone ever
since he
reappeared on the chess scene so uh
definitely uh
uh a normal result uh so yeah
uh that's the game and the match i do
hope you guys enjoyed it
if we don't see each other uh you know
anymore after this game uh
today then happy new year to everyone
may you have a better year than uh the
the the previous one was like i said if
you're interested in the captures merch
first link in the description below you
can get one for yourself or your you
know
parents or grandparents whatever they're
looking looking really awesome
uh i would like to thank lorraine moore
robert cretchmar mark buxton pratyush
gosh and martin georg paparich for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have a happy new year everyone